[Music]
in Good Samaritan news submitted by my
dog's name is Aspen Aspen like Colorado
yeah a husband dog has been that always
worse to think of dumb dumber always and
Samson Samson Samson I remember those to
hold a briefcase
yeah he's like we got to give it to mr.
Samsonite oh yeah there's a few movies
that had been best branding for products
like Free Willy there was a part where
he opened up this hash brown and he was
eating it it was like a McDonald's ad
like it within the movie ever since then
I wanted to eat a hash brown ever since
I want to eat a well you always wanted
to try killing whale always a man
stepped in front of a machete to help
save a stranger that's Dean yes how'd
you do that
what do you mean step in front of them
it was a stranger like a cute little
baby oh no was it a hot lady I don't
know if she's hot it was a lady ulterior
motives well I mean he had a girlfriend
too Oh threesome yeah yeah he's always
looking to level up not his wife always
oh that's like a quick reaction oh sit
in front or like hey sometimes I just
watch and I go oh oh oh you don't know
cuz like it's like instinct so you don't
know what your fight-or-flight is if you
are fight-or-flight and I guarantee if
you slow that clip down it's him going
up to grab her and put her in front of
him but he wasn't fast enough so he just
got hit first ya know so this happened
in Bakersfield here oh [ __ ] it was this
man hunting down his ex-girlfriend with
a machete and the this girl she ended up
running into a Starbucks and started
screaming like help help he's gonna kill
me
went into the wrong one you gotta go to
a gym or somewhere else like a Starbucks
like I don't know if anybody in this
bunch of screenwriters like yeah there's
a messenger bags like yeah cuz there
were options you're right there was a
gym it was a fire department it was
police I'd pick the fire department yeah
books
of all of you fellas some coffee yeah I
wanted guys with horn-rimmed glasses to
protect me
it's like dive bar or Starbucks
Starbucks or police department yeah
she's like how about I know fans of
Radiohead yeah so she ran in there and
everyone like they just started running
away like I said Starbucks yeah but then
that's when Blaine Blaine is a hero here
he started running towards the girl and
trying to like help her and then that's
when he confronted Robert who was the
one chasing down his ex and he just got
[ __ ] up so I'm gonna show my gosh
I know there's not a video they attack
I'm gonna show you a video like a music
oh no I hope he's okay when he's all cut
up
in danger that could you just let her
die
man Robert Revis according to court
documents Revis has been in trouble for
domestic violence before he was stabbed
many times supper Wow right fingers in
mobile on my crotch through his arms and
his knee in all result to be close to
200 stitches [ __ ] nice guy that grow
better American no 100 stitches
bro you are a brave man yeah and also
not too smart a dumb man and a brave man
sometimes goes hand in hand yes I've
heard a story first I'd be like wait
what the [ __ ] did she do to you and she
stole all his [ __ ] money I go ahead
you just don't know you don't like Bart
right now I would have believed well he
isn't Bart sighs you know he's sitting
alone sure he was chair though yeah if I
was brave enough to but think about like
hey I gotta stop this guy I don't think
I would have done this hey hey hey
I would have been like okay there's
chance if I whip it up no I don't think
I I just yeah I don't know if I would
have done like yeah you went in there
barehanded yeah you try to talk it out
where you should go physical and like if
the guy thinks that you have a weapon
hosel starts to me harder I feel like
but that guy looks tall and and the
other guy looks shorter yeah so I I feel
like if the guy was shorter you might
feel more confident too that guy is
absolutely a hero but I kind of hate it
when they say that they're heroes is
that weird
I always like it when like I'm not a
hero I did what every hero he was like a
woman was gonna die and I had to do
something that's why I'm here so you
don't think he kind of is you know I
used to defend why he did oh I really
love it no I'm just um I'm not saying
that what I'm saying he's a hero but I
like that when everyone else just don't
like that he didn't say I'm not a hero
yeah I like that [ __ ] I don't know I
Steve the reporter off camera he just
goes like this by the way you're not a
[ __ ] hero
no but I think he is a hero oh it's just
that when you call yourself a hero it's
not we didn't call himself he Ted
indirectly called something you want
more humility yes thank you the reporter
was like why did you do that way you did
like why did you do that for a stranger
and he was like well I just couldn't let
a stranger died nobody I'm Steve wants a
superhero line like I did what any great
man that's right foot [ __ ] like I'm and
everybody should do this I'm gonna be
hero PR because I think oh wait but it's
a Python the cleaner wind doing oh thank
me for being a DC Mike do not crazy
you're being a little unreasonable yeah
be very unreasonable
let me just get it good at this clear
instead of saying oh I just couldn't let
a woman die you want him to say I did
what any great man would do great man
sir no decent man said would any decent
man any great man would be a sign I did
what any decent man would do yeah Julia
we live in an equal world now like what
about the stories of women standing in
front of men if I'm being chased by a
guy with a machete and I'm like help me
please and then I go into a nail salon I
expect a lady to jump out and save me
first and now you do yeah there are men
yeah exactly I have seen videos of old
women coming out and like all women are
different you're [ __ ] y'all talking
about moms you just seen mom's oh yeah
wait I got it no I feel like grandma's
or like even ballsier than young males
that's true because you know what that I
mama bear instincts come in you're crazy
I got a no Steve yeah you just got cut
up by machete I'm a reporter
yeah why did you jump in front of a
machete for a stranger I just doing what
anybody would done information and sorry
my [ __ ] gases are bleeding really
hard right now but
well I am sorry sir but not anyone would
have done it because nobody else did it
they all ran away why did you do it why
do I feel like any reasonable person in
this situation what it does I can't
speak closer you saying that you're
visible that big reasonable is pretty
you think you're a [ __ ] hero sir I
think it's by far the most biased
reporter yeah holy [ __ ]
what channel am i on right what if Jesus
no that's not much my channel is hyung
the humble heroes Channel yeah what have
you said this like he was like I did it
cuz I know [ __ ] and all these
[ __ ] over here are [ __ ] victim
being all gloating that he's a hero
no they're all [ __ ] boys would you know
it's just like when they interview what
a great contribution Niki thank you know
when they interview World War two
veterans who stormed the beaches of
Normandy these cats don't talk about how
they're heroes you want to hear no no I
just you're just mad that you did get
cut by machete should we switch chairs
you're saying some [ __ ] then I'm like
understand you just be this is why she
wanted to switch chairs yeah she wants
to see you get you all I scream at you
it's just that
look I just feel like I don't know like
I'm debating like a little new right now
it's like that's a noodle
yeah like a little bendy noodle like I
don't know I don't think I'm getting
your best tape and my crazier this guy
called himself a hero let's play back
you know what's happening it's so funny
his chairs getting lower lower
started to name calling me a noodle or a
lot lower than this lower mess in this
debate you had to name call me a noodle
that's the debate you want to know the
[ __ ] funny thing was you gonna
divorce you over ice cubes but this okay
yeah playback potato let's do this [ __ ]
some stuff having a service today
there's a person major you couldn't just
let her die just show I'm a hero leave I
said it right with a cut I commend this
man I'm merely talking about his own PR
like his own like way of speaking about
the answer I couldn't let a woman die is
different than oh I did what any
reasonable person would do how the [ __ ]
is that
yeah I hate that [ __ ] Jordan straw
dude why good exactly is a reasonable
and good measure that was just saying
well why why are you chasing her with a
machete what did she do to you she
[ __ ] you over then go ahead and kill
her that's the same great great from a
greater man you would never say it about
himself by the way and that's what makes
him so special i right it's the whole
thing where it's like it's like hey look
you know anybody like literally saw the
light a cigarette right now at Starbucks
not is that do they have knives in the
kitchen he said he said I couldn't let a
woman die exactly
cigarettes missing he's putting on
sunglasses after second he's [ __ ]
opening a CSI Miami [ __ ] Michelle any
normal decent person wouldn't even go in
front of the machete yeah wait so the
person passes they're talking from
behind killing the Leland chair between
ya throwing [ __ ] out of you guys are all
way bigger heroes no no no we're cowards
because that's how we're gonna stay
alive this guy this guy's like this he's
like this he's like listen one's about
to get taken out by machete and I said
and he is a hero but when you when you
that's a brave ass [ __ ] it is braver
than [ __ ] he is braver than anything
I'll do in my life I am merely stating a
thing about the way that he talks about
himself that's it I think we should just
start chucking chairs and tables
I couldn't let someone die I've been
bragging
[Music]